- Is Discord trying to screw
you out of a class-action?
Is BetterHelp offering fake therapy?
Let's find out.
(chiming music)
Hey LegalEagles, it's time to
litigate the terms of service
for Discord and BetterHelp.
If you have a suggestion
for the next legal topic,
please leave it below, and
if you disagree with me,
please be sure to leave your comment
in the form of an objection.
But remember to keep things civil,
because Stella, the Legal Beagle,
carries the gavel of justice,
and she's not afraid to use
it in the comments section.
Alright, let's think like a lawyer.
Today we're talking
TOS's, terms of service.
These are usually really
dry, boring contracts,
but there are two particular
TOS's in the news recently,
those from Discord and
BetterHelp, and not in a good way.
There are two issues that
I wanna discuss today.
Number one, is Discord's
arbitration clause
and class-action waiver legal?
And number two, does BetterHelp's terms
mean that they are offering sham services?
What is a TOS, or term of service?
A term of service is that
long contract that you sign
when you sign up for a
website, or some software,
that governs your relationship.
And I'm sure, everyone here
has read the entire contract
before clicking accept,
and then going on to use a website, right?
Right, no one reads all
of the terms of service,
but despite the fact
that you may not read it,
the term of service still
governs the relationship
between you and that website,
or the software that you're using.
The term of service will
do a couple of things.
Number one, they set out the
rules by which you must abide
if you are going to continue to use
their software or service.
And number two, they also provide
the obligations that the
company is going to give to you
in return for you being a user
of that website or software.
But a term of service doesn't have
to have any particular terms.
It can lay out rules,
it can create obligations
on behalf of the website,
it can create obligations on behalf
of the user to the website.
Or, it can be simply a disclaimer,
that disclaims any kind of warranty,
or any kind of relationship at all
between the website itself,
and the users of that website,
to try and get rid of liability
as between the users
and the website itself.
Today we're going to talk
about two TOS's in particular,
those from a company called Discord,
which provides VOIP, or VoIP services,
and the second from a
company called BetterHelp,
which provides online teletherapy
services to its users.
The first TOS I wanna
discuss comes from Discord.
What's controversial here
is that a few days ago,
Discord created a new term in their TOS
that is a class-action waiver.
Ostensibly, it prevents any
user of the Discord services
from filing a class-action
lawsuit, and instead requires
those users to go into what's
called binding arbitration,
instead of using the courts.
So let's take a step back first,
and talk about what is a class-action?
A class action is a way of aggregating
harms that are so small, that
no one would ever file suit,
as a result of that particular harm.
There was a movement that
started in the states,
and then was governed
mostly by federal law,
which allows a bunch of
really small claimants
to aggregate their claims together.
Now, there are a ton of requirements.
Rule 23 of the Federal
Rules of Civil Procedure
requires that you have to have
things like an adequate class
that must be ascertainable.
There must be enough of those claims
to make it basically worthwhile,
to file a class-action suit.
Those claimants must have a common claim,
and that the class representative
must have a claim that's typical,
of those common claims of the class.
And there are other requirements,
like the representative counsel
must be adequate and a
number of other things.
But the bottom line is that
a class-action lawsuit is
a way for one, or a
handful of class members
to basically put forward a case
on behalf of the entire class of people.
So instead of just filing
suit on behalf of yourself,
as you would in a normal lawsuit,
you're filing suit with
the help of your attorneys
on behalf of hundreds
potentially thousands,
and sometimes even millions of people.
And by aggregating all of
those small things together,
you create a financial incentive
to go forward with that case.
A class action lawsuit historically
has been done by the attorney general,
but now for the most part it's
done by private individuals.
So you might ask yourself,
why would someone file
a class-action lawsuit?
Well, it's partially
the people themselves,
and it's partially the attorneys.
The attorneys are gonna get
a large cut of the payout.
Often you are aggregating so many
of these small claims together,
that a class-action lawsuit is
often a bet the company case.
So that if the company lost it,
and had to pay out what
the plaintiff is claiming,
it might bankrupt the entire company.
I've handled a ton of
class-actions before,
usually defending very innocent companies
from scurrilous plaintiff attorneys
just trying to make a buck.
But, you know, I've also been
a member of a class before,
and I've gotten one of
those two dollar checks
from being a class member in a very
small class-action recovery.
So, I see it both ways.
I understand the need
for companies to have
a punitive action taken against them,
when they've clearly done something wrong,
but I've also seen plaintiff's
attorneys out there
just in it to get the attorney's fees
from that big pool of money.
So Discord changed its term of service,
and now requires a class-action waiver,
and a private arbitration clause.
Which means instead of being able to use
the regular court system,
and using a class-action in
they force you into private arbitration,
where you're not able to
file a class-action lawsuit.
Now, arbitration sounds scary,
but arbitration is really just
an informal version of court.
The main difference is that generally,
both parties have to hire the arbitrator,
so instead of regular court
where you're not paying
for the salary of the
judge, in arbitration,
both sides usually have to pay
for the arbitrator's salary.
So it's more informal, you can
set whatever rules you want,
as long as they're agreed
upon by both sides,
and you have to pay for
the arbitrators time.
Now, Discord came out
with a statement defending
their decision to include
these arbitration agreements,
saying that class-actions can be very bad.
They're used by attorneys
to get huge fees,
and they take those fees
out of the class recovery,
and that people often
get really small rewards
they don't care about
and they often just
throw away those checks.
Now all of those things are in fact true,
but you could see them
as features, not bugs.
Again, often if people
weren't able to aggregate
all these claims, they never
would have been incentivized
to file the suit in the first place.
And believe me, lawyers
don't like to work for free,
so unless there is a big enough incentive,
they won't handle those cases.
I've handled both court
cases and arbitration,
and I can't say for a fact that
one is necessarily better than the other.
Arbitration is almost certainly faster,
because courts are really backed up.
Arbitration gives you
individualized attention,
where as in court the judge
is spreading his of her time,
between hundreds or thousands
of different cases at any given time,
where as in arbitration,
you might get one to three retired judges
who probably aren't
handling that many cases.
Arbitration is generally
way more expensive
because both parties have to pay
the arbitrator's hourly.
And I think the last arbitrator
I had to hire was $900 an hour.
They can charge these
fees because they have
a certain pedigree from being ex-judges
and really knowing what
they're talking about,
and good arbitrators are
really important to hire.
But I can't say that an
arbitration necessarily
favors the defendant, which
is something that I see
people saying all the time.
I think people usually say
that because of the cost,
but again, arbitrators themselves
are just as good as regular judges,
so I don't think that they are going to be
biased in favor of the
defendant, necessarily.
Here in particular though,
the fees issue isn't as bad
as it normally would be.
In Discord's TOS they say
specifically that they will pay
for any fees over what it
would cost to file in court,
unless the arbitrator
finds that the case itself
was filed frivolously.
So what are the main
complaints that you might have
about arbitration, in
the consumer context,
where what consumer is gonna want to fight
a hundred dollar case,
if they're gonna have to pay out
hundreds of dollars in
fees to the arbitrator.
Well here, Discord is already agreeing
to pay for the fees of the arbitrator.
All you have to pay for
are the normal filing fees
that it would cost to file suit.
Now those themselves can be
in the hundreds of dollars,
but still, that nothing
compared to paying an arbitrator
$900 an hour for dozens,
if not hundreds of hours.
Now interestingly, this
actually might give
you more leverage against Discord
because since Discord is on the hook
to pay for these arbitrator services,
Discord might rather just settle the case
for a nominal fee instead
of having to go through
expensive arbitration,
where they're paying
for not only their own attorneys,
but also the fees of
the arbitrator as well.
So ironically, this term of service
may actually give some
leverage to the consumer.
But on the other hand,
the TOS does clearly require you to waive
your class-action rights,
so you can't file a class-action lawsuit.
Now, the big benefit as we discussed
is being able to aggregate
all the small claims
that no one would individually
want to file suit over.
And instead, it requires you to file
an individual suit on your own basis.
So you lose the benefit
of having this litigation,
if there is litigation taken care
of for you by some other attorney
and some other representative plaintiff.
And frankly, it's a
relatively small chance
that it's going to be relevant to you,
and an even smaller chance
that it's a recovery that you care about.
But, it certainly does
prevent anyone from taking
punitive action against Discord
for violation of the law,
and some people think that lawsuits,
and especially class-action lawsuits,
are created specifically
for their punitive action
to make sure companies stay in line,
even when the recoveries are
very very small on an individual basis.
So at the end of the day,
this is a mixed bag for
the users of Discord.
It's not as scary as it first seems,
but there's actually some
good things in there.
It allows you to go through arbitration,
which can be much faster than courts,
and much more informal, on Discord's dime.
However, you do give up the right
to file class-action lawsuit,
and you may lose out on some small checks
that would have been done
by class-action attorneys
and class-action plaintiffs,
in some other universe.
So there are some good things,
and some bad things in
this new Discord TOS.
But the question is, is it legal?
Well, recent supreme court
does in fact allow these
class-action waivers.
Starting in 2011, in the
AT&T versus Concepcion case,
and recently reaffirmed this
year in Epic versus Lewis,
and Ernst and Young versus Morris,
class-action waivers are enforceable,
and companies can force you
into private arbitration.
So you might not like it,
but it's probably legal.
So let's move on to the
second term of service,
that from the company called BetterHelp.
My understanding is that BetterHelp
is an online platform that links
online therapists with consumers.
I've never used BetterHelp,
unlike a lot of people on YouTube,
I am not sponsored by BetterHelp,
but I can certainly see the benefit of
being able to just dial up
a therapist using Skype,
instead of having to
drive over to a therapist
and see them in person.
Maybe that's a good service, I don't know.
But what I can tell you is that
there is a huge controversy
brewing over BetterHelp's term of service.
As of a few weeks ago,
the BetterHelp TOS implied that
they didn't the credentials
or the background of all the
therapeutic professionals
that they use to link up
between consumers and the therapist.
So, let's look at this disclaimer
in the original terms of service.
It seems pretty clear that the old TOS
says that BetterHelp was
not obligated to check out
the background or the credentials
of the therapists that they use.
Now, even as originally written,
this is a floor, this is
a disclaimer of liability,
it's a statement that
there is no obligation,
but it's not a statement that
BetterHelp was absolutely not
checking on their professionals.
According to BetterHelp themselves,
they were checking on the backgrounds
and credentials of their therapists,
but they didn't want to be on the hook
for misstatements by those therapists,
and they didn't want to be
obligated to undertake that
even though they were generally
providing that service.
Phil DeFranco did an
entire video about this,
I'll link to that down below,
and from what I can piece together,
he seems to get things more or less right.
- From that terms of service,
there's this question
that pops up, okay, are you just allowing
anyone to say that they're a counselor?
Because that language is concerning
and is completely alien
to my understanding
of how they go and vet these people.
From here I then reached out
to our contact at BetterHelp
we ended up being connected
with the founder of BetterHelp,
Alon Matas, and he gave me a statement
where at one point he talked
about the terms and conditions
and questions, saying The
Terms and Conditions document
typically provides the legalese
that defines the extent of liability
and mitigates legal risks
associated with such platforms.
We will be revising the
Terms and Conditions document
so it more closely matches
the vetting process
we currently conduct.
- This is kind of standard legalese
that you'll see in a TOS like this.
It's about preventing legal liability,
it is not a statement that BetterHelp was
actively turning a blind
eye to their therapists.
And my understanding is that
in a reaction to this controversy,
BetterHelp has revised
their term of service
to more accurately reflect
what they actually do,
and now they are taking on
the affirmative legal burden
associated with those actions.
But even as originally written,
it doesn't seem like this was
much to do about anything.
Additionally, PewDiePie,
who seems to have an
ax to grind in this
particular controversy,
was aggrieved by BetterHelp's
disclaimer of warranty,
pointing out that BetterHelp stated that
they don't stand by their professionals.
Now this is called a disclaimer.
This is very, very common.
In fact, I would bet that in the TOS
of almost every website
you interact with there is
a disclaimer, that says
they disclaim any warranty
for the services that they provide.
And really, it's not surprising that
BetterHelp would be any different.
BetterHelp is basically just a platform
that links up online
therapists to patients,
so it's not surprising that the platform
would want to disclaim liability
from the independent contractors
that it contracts with.
This is pretty standard
for any kind of platform,
and almost any website
that you do business with.
For example, my guess is
that if you hire a plumber
through Angie's List, Angie's
List is not going to guarantee
the work of that plumber.
This kind of disclaimer
is very very common,
and it's certainly nothing
to freak out about.
Similar terms are probably behind
every website that you visit,
and govern every relationship
with any platform that you use.
So I can't say whether you
should go to BetterHelp
for therapy services,
but I can say you should
not go to PewDiePie for legal advice.
Do you agree?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and until next time,
I'll see you in court.